o la saludamos a la audiencia de france
24 estamos de regreso con una nueva
entrevista un estudio absolutamente
inédito y también pionero en américa
latina realizado por la fundación más
igualdad de perú reveló el impacto que
tiene la discriminación hacia la
comunidad lgtb
en el éxodo de profesionales de este
país y para dialogar sobre este tema nos
acompaña la luz persa tuit el
profesional de la arquitectura y fundó
epicentro trujillo una organización que
buscaba promover el desarrollo de la
comunidad lg más a través de un espacio
de socialización en trujillo y fue parte
del universo de personas que
participaron de este estudio al que
hacíamos referencia luther salto y
muchísimas gracias en primer lugar por
participar de la entrevista de france 24
gracias a ustedes por la invitación
bueno en primer lugar la teorización no
clásica por supuesto sobre lo que es el
movimiento migratorio o lo que suele ser
se centra principalmente a menudo en lo
que son las causas económicas para
decidir irse de un país a otro no
obstante existen muchas otras razones no
como bien lo señala el estudio al que
hacemos referencia que este motivo vamos
a dejar perú
en mi caso yo salí para visitar a mi
hermana ella vive quien son paulo y
encontré un espacio mucho más amigable
mucho más
que tiene más tolerancia a personas lgtb
y que digamos no tiene esta visión tan
cerrada de lo que es la vida no en este
sentido y esa oportunidad vi lo que
tenía en perú y aproveché para quedarme
ahora looper en los últimos tiempos en
muchos países y regiones ha habido
ciertos avances no en el reconocimiento
sobre todo legal de derechos de las
personas lgtb de más pero contanos qué
suceden pero cuál es la realidad en este
país de sudamérica
en realidad perú es uno de los pocos
países en sudamérica que no tiene muchos
avances en materia de derechos para las
personas que la gente q no inclusive
actualmente dentro del congreso hay
algunos proyectos de ley que están ya
bastante tiempo desde el 2016 2017 que
fueron presentados que es el proyecto de
ley de matrimonio igualitario y el de
ley de identidad de género que
recientemente fue discutido en una de
las comisiones no en la condición de
mujer y familia y ahora debemos esperar
a que pase todavía por otra comisión que
es la comisión de constitución para
pasar al pleno
ahora como decíamos te dedicas a la
arquitectura no contamos te tocó vivir
discriminación en el ámbito profesional
en perú y por fuera del ámbito laboral
en qué sectores también has recibido
este tipo de actitudes
y yo soy el formado en arquitectura no
trabajé unos años en la carrera
lamentablemente por cuestiones ligadas a
discriminación no lamentablemente fui a
mi contrato terminó
porque el proyecto había terminado pero
luego me enteré que ir contratado a más
gente
entonces fue
[Música]
un caso directamente relacionado a mi
orientación sexual y expresión de género
no además qué
digamos durante ese año tuve una mayor
visibilidad en lo que es el movimiento
de la gente y ccoo así que digamos hay
cosas que están ligadas felizmente las
otras aleaciones que trabajan en perú no
tuve ese inconveniente porque eran temas
relacionados justamente a derechos
humanos o trabajo específicamente
relacionado con población de sergio y
blake no en ese sentido tuve problemas
pero digamos en mi formación si tuve que
y dejar de lado la carrera
hacías referencia recién a lo que es la
visibilidad no hoy precisamente en el
estudio de la fundación más igualdad al
que estamos haciendo referencia se
concluyó que el 90 por ciento de los
emigrantes peruanos el gti q es más
visible en sus países de residencia con
un sólo el 10 por ciento de lo que era
en perú o sea tienen un 90 por ciento de
visibilidad fuera de perú y tan sólo un
10 por ciento de visibilidad en perú no
aclaremos que cuando decimos visibilidad
hacemos referencia a expresarse y
manifestarse abiertamente tal cual como
uno es no cómo fue tu experiencia en
este sentido en perú y en brasil
en este caso en perú yo era bastante
visible no por muchos años fui
director de vicente trujillo en alguna
organización diferente y como ya lo
había mencionado al inicio y luego eso
me acarreó algunas alumnas
inconvenientes porque obviamente hay
gente en ciudades pequeñas como trujillo
que no les gusta trabajar con personas
del g20
pero estas personas el ejercicio
visibles vine aquí a brasil encontré un
espacio mucho más amigable mucho más
abierto a la diversidad no actualmente
trabajo en una empresa donde no
cuestionan mi sexualidad no cuestionan
la ropa que uso no inclusive ellos
maquillado trabajar
he ido en faldas y yo nunca me
criticaron eso nunca me dijeron porque
bien dices y si no me preguntaban cómo
iba todo en casa sabes
ahora esto se vincula a otro aspecto que
menciona el estudio el que estoy
haciendo referencia porque no solo hay
un mayor bienestar económico señala la
mayoría de las personas encuestadas sino
también hacen referencia a lo que estás
diciendo vos no hay una mayor percepción
de respeto por parte de la comunidad y
también como una suerte de red de apoyo
no en relación a la orientación sexual
oa las identidades de género esto en vos
por lo que contase ha sido bien marcado
el cambio no
sí totalmente inclusive en el empresa
donde yo trabajo tiene un área de
diversidad
y además ha sido reconocida como una
organización una empresa lg better
friendly intentado brasil no hay una
gran cantidad de funcionarios
funcionarias que son el eje better you
know y que inclusive tienen cargos del
líder anza no algo que es muy poco común
en perú salvo que sean personas que sean
más de lo normal y que digamos su
sexualidad esté guardado en un armario
ahora esto que estás contando los
fuertes llevo de alguna manera a sentir
no sé cierto desarraigo con respecto a
tu país pero una cierta sensación de no
aceptación de quizás incluso de rechazo
quizás
yo sí sentía bastante rechazo en mi país
de origen no en perú sentía que
cualquier cosa que yo haga no iba a ser
suficiente no no sólo a nivel social
sino a nivel legal
a pesar de que
trabajaba arduamente digamos o
levantando agendas relacionadas al
reconocimiento de derechos para personas
el eje 25 lamentablemente
desde los poderes tanto legislativo
ejecutivo judicial no había un avance
tan grande no el avance era muy lento
para digamos como hasta latinoamérica o
sudamérica en este caso no como es el
contexto que rodea perú es un contexto
mucho más amigable con muchísimas más
leyes y normas que protegen a las
personas el eje métrico y sin embargo
perú sería manteniéndose en ese mismo
espacio d
de tiempo sabes cómo que si se hubiera
detenido en 1800 kirchnerista en
realidad porque es triste sentir que no
eres bienvenido en tu país
y regresaría a ser perú en algún momento
solamente regresaría para visitar no
volvería para vivir porque sentiría que
las cosas que logrado porque un montón
de cosas que he logrado aquí
para volver a un lugar en donde lo tengo
absolutamente nada y un lugar que además
me rechaza y un lugar que preferiría
verme invisible
como que la balanza está un poco
desigual no
ahora no sólo se están perjudicando
muchísimas personas no que se tienen que
ir del país pero también se perjudica al
perder talentos profesionales muchísimas
personas que abandonan el país verdad
así es justamente hubo un
un reportaje hace poco tiempo que
hablaba justamente de la fuga de talento
de perú sobre todo
personas que están relacionadas de
ciencia altos ejecutivos etcétera lo que
justamente se iban de perú por la falta
de reconocimiento de derechos y por las
diversas formas de violencia a las que
estábamos expuestos
hablando de formas de violencia no a la
que está expuesta la comunidad lgtb más
de perú en el estudio también hacen
referencia a que el 40 por ciento de las
personas que participaron de estas
encuestas afirman haber sido sometidas a
la que son conocidas como terapias de
reconversión no incluso en el año 2021
como activista tenés información al
respecto allegados personas que te han
consultado al respecto
mira
no conozco ningún caso directo pero sí
conozco casos por ejemplo de gente que
viva epicentro trujillo y que nos
comentaba que a veces
la familia no se ha llevado a un pastor
para que le rece y los cure
lo que sí he visto de manera directa fue
un caso de violación correctiva a una
gran amiga mía lesbiana lo que su mejor
amigo las 'yellow para sanar la sabes
una terrible terrible terrible lo que
estás contando la luz era una aberración
absoluta ahora para ir finalizando esta
entrevista
qué mensaje tienes para las personas
lgtb que todavía están en perú no y que
están sufriendo discriminación y
muchísimas de las violencias a las que
hiciste referencia a lo largo de esta
entrevista
invitar básicamente a poder primero
buscar espacios de socialización y
espacios de soporte es sumamente
importante ello poder saber de qué
tienes personas con las que contar y
luego atreverse a salir del closet es
sumamente importante poder hacerlo
porque lo que necesitamos difícil y dad
luther salto y muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
ha sido un placer dialogar contigo
gracias por favor gracias a ti a nuestra
audiencia como siempre invitamos a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france24 punto
com
[Música]
y